se trata de uno de los mayores reveses
en el terreno material de las fuerzas
rusas el buque insignia de la flota rusa
en el mar negro con más de 500 personas
a bordo está gravemente dañado debido a
un incendio la munición explotó a bordo
y toda la tripulación fue evacuada
posteriormente el ministerio de defensa
ruso informó que el incendio había sido
controlado y que la embarcación será
llevada a puerto pero kiev tiene una
versión diferente de los acontecimientos
las autoridades locales dicen que el
barco fue alcanzado por misiles
ucranianos y que rusia tuvo que evacuar
de urgencia a los marineros a bordo
en la región del mar negro el crucero
box ba fue alcanzado por misiles
antibuque neptune el buque insignia de
la flota rusa del mar negro sufrió daños
importantes se inició un incendio otros
barcos intentaron prestar ayuda pero la
tormenta y la potente explosión de
munición volcaron el barco y comenzó a
hundirse upton over el barco había
participado en un ataque en el que
fueron capturados 19 marineros
ucranianos a finales de febrero también
jugó un rol clave en la campaña militar
rusa en siria que comenzó en 2015 ahora
las operaciones en el mar negro son muy
importantes por parte de rusia para
apoyar a las fuerzas terrestres en el
sur y en el este
moscú ba es el segundo barco ruso que
sufre daños importantes desde el
comienzo de la guerra